foreign
this you shared with me this is written
by a woman named Mandy statmiller I
think well rabbit hold 70 number 78 Dana
reverses the story the media doesn't
want you to read
uh this is a story unparalleled and
media censorship about deadly white male
violence against a lesbian interracial
couple in their black son when the media
goes silent there was always a reason
why
um
Mandy gives a trigger warning in this
piece you give me a trigger warning when
you shared it with me which I almost
never do you don't yeah
um and it this the story warrants it
this is
this is so horrifying you really can't
imagine
what is going on but the the the very
thumbnail version is that this guy
um
uh started you know claim claims to be
trans started invading women's spaces
including uh for instance this um I
think it's called mishfest the I may
have this wrong but the the famous and
long-lasting Women's Music Festival in
Michigan that was held every summer
until these
trans women started invading it with
violence and aggression and all of this
and they basically had to shut it down
so you know and yet another example of
women's spaces not being allowed to be
one in spaces because people who want
women get to say they're women and
somehow you're not allowed to say no
you're not
this man is so full of rage and
particularly at one of the women in this
interracial lesbian couple
that he showed up at their house and he
he killed both of the women and their 19
year old son who happened to have been
adopted as I think a baby from Africa he
had just graduated from high school he
was a stellar student he was yeah he was
going on to great things and
um he slaughtered all of them and the
the
number of things that he did to the
woman whom he hated most as he killed
her are extraordinary
we've not heard about this story that's
the other story what we did hear about
apparently and I don't remember this but
what Mandy
um the author of this piece reports is
that this guy Dana Rivers
was lauded in the liberal media back in
the 90s when he first came out as trans
and uh was was just a media darling for
a while for being so brave
and the fact is that uh
you know he never really passed and so
women who saw him coming into women's
faces would say things to him and uh on
some of those women he took out his rage
to such a degree that um they're now
dead
brutally so and he is likely to be like
he took away the iPad or something of
the of the young man who he killed and
he was still wearing it on his person
when he turned himself in so you know
there's really no ambiguity about
whether or not he committed these crimes
but because of new law in California at
the point that he's convicted he's going
to go to women's prison
yeah it's really you know and we pointed
out
years ago at this point
um that this was the danger that you
know we're talking about all kinds of
things that are yes horrifying like the
fact that men can now compete against
women in women's sports
um but the you know the deep end of the
pool really is prison right at the point
that somebody can decide that they go to
a women's prison irrespective of what
they've been convicted of
um irrespective of what uh kinds what
phenotype they have just show my screen
here these are the people who were
killed
well um but you know this is an a
completely unfudgable issue right the
fact is men who are capable of raping
women should not be in a women's prison
now in this case you've got a guy who is
not only physically enabled as a man he
still retains his penis but he is
obviously there's so many quotes in this
thing that make it clear that this is
the most deeply misogynistic person
right in fact there's one violently like
rape fantasy that he published as porn
on Amazon and some of it is still up yes
multiple
books that he is self-published on
Amazon that contain just the most
twisted and bizarre the most extreme
anti-female kinds of
some sex rape violent fantasy stuff that
the idea that any Court would do
anything other than look at him and say
no dude
um you're you're going to a maximum
security Men's prison is uh you know
that's the only rational thing to do
with somebody this depraved and
dangerous that's right um and
the fact I mean I really see this as two
stories one there is the terrifying very
awful story that Mandy stepmiller has
written here yeah
and then there's the story of the fact
that it's not being covered yeah right
you are being told we are all being told
that trans is an important issue and
that in order for justice to Prevail we
must provide
the right to self-defying yeah okay then
some of us say well
in principle you should have the right
to self-define until you get to the
place where that's a threat to other
people's rights and then there's
something that absolutely has to be
discussed oh really you you know you
really want to keep these people from
enjoying the protection of a space that
matches their internal uh sense of
themselves yes no I'm most worried about
prison like let's go to the person but
also of course women are allowed to have
women only spaces men are allowed to
have mentally spaces of course but my
point isn't that that's an ambiguous
case my point is we have a perfectly
unambiguous case there's no argument to
be made that a person like this
belongs in a women's prison because he
says so well really you think somebody
would identify as female just to go to a
women's prison yes I do and I've said so
before this case became public right
okay and that's I mean the the other guy
from the Wii Spa thing you know he he
says as much in his answer this is part
of why I I feel pretty very confident
about my assessment of him is he says
well you know I've just really felt this
way and also prison wasn't a good match
for me like of course course Men's
prison is a good match for you I don't
it's a good match for just about anyone
right like it's not that that was it's
just so so obvious a thing to say and to
think that that's like well that must
mean I'm a woman Inside It's like no
that means prison sucks but
but I'm trying to get at this other
point which is okay
people on side a
said in order to be just in order to be
kind in order to be decent we must carve
out the space to self-define then some
of us said that is going to cause you
problems when you get to things like
women's sports women only spaces women's
prison and they said no it won't because
that would require somebody to identify
as female in order to game the system
yeah happens all the time really no it
doesn't happen you're exaggerating how
often it happens hey take a look at this
the most horrifying story of a violent
sexually motivated Murder by somebody
who just happens to have published
several self-published several books you
know in which he explores these kind of
depraved fantasies
so this is the end of that argument
except it took Mandy's stepmiller to
write it on her sub stack in order for
us even to have access to the case
because the point is the system is now
so biased in favor of this argument that
it will actually obscure a case like
this and in fact it's been now uh at
least
many days since I read it so I don't
remember if I've got this exactly right
but um
oh what was I going to say the uh
I've now lost it uh it'll come back okay
uh let me read a couple things yeah and
I'll come back to you sure
to paraphrase spiked online how you
identify as a man matters about as much
as whether you feel like your
criminality is actually Justified and
fully righteous because all the women
you've assaulted deserved it
imagine if serial killers and child
rapists could start identify could start
to identify as being innocent and that
was respected too
identity is an insult to the brutality
of reality
reality is that almost 100 of those
convicted of sexual violence are male 98
to be exact in UK prisons almost half of
those who identify with synthetic sex
identities identities have been
convicted of sexual offenses
incidentally the phrase synthetic sex
identities is excellent and that is um
that is what is being used here to
indicate those who are trying to pass is
the sex that they are not
there is not a female prisoner on Earth
who deserves the punishment of being
housed with Dana Rivers a psychopathic
Revenge obsessed male who has already
taken the lives of two women in their
family I ask you how many more women
does Rivers have to kill before all the
requests to be kind becomes a little too
much for all of us to bear
so yeah I do have it
um
two things one let us just notice that
the fools who have engineered our new
system
um
their logic
right that in fact even you know we've
used these same cases before but Caitlyn
Jenner did not win the men's decathlon
right Bruce Jenner did it is absurd to
have a system in which we cannot talk
about Bruce Jenner's you know it is
perfectly valid to say Bruce Jenner won
the men's decathlon later transitioned
to become Caitlyn Jenner who identifies
as female that is all factual but we're
not allowed to say it because of this
phony concept of dead naming now here's
the thing right this absurd idea that
you should be able to identify as
innocent is actually perfectly logically
consistent with the idea that dead
naming is a problem
the idea that you could identify as
innocent to escape responsibility for a
crime is perfectly logically consistent
with the idea that it is wrong to dead
name uh Caitlyn Jenner by talking about
her Olympic Triumph is Bruce right the
point is if you can forbid us to talk
about the actual manner in which you won
some award in the past then you can also
walk away from a crime that you've
committed because you are now
identifying as somebody different this
is a new person that person is dead oh
yes he committed a crime but he is now
dead right that is nonsense is there any
chance I would not have expected to find
myself steel Manning any part of their
argument but is there any chance
that they are a little bit confused
by the fact that for some crimes intent
does matter
right that murder and manslaughter are
actually different crimes even if the
effect on the person who's been who's
been killed is the same
I don't I don't quite get your argument
I would say intent always matters right
there is gross negligence but it's very
different but you're you know
I don't care if you think you're
innocent if you're not you're not
I do care a little bit if you were
trying to kill that person as opposed to
if you weren't killing that person
because it says some different things
about your mental state and who you are
as a human being and what your
likelihood is of doing such a thing
again in the future right I mean what so
I I guess because intent is a feature of
the Mind
it does take it into the space of well
I'm just creating it like this is just
this is this is something that bubbles
up from my mind and therefore maybe all
reality is like that okay
more sympathetic to the steel Manning if
the very people who would be uh confused
in this way we're not also the people
who claim intent doesn't matter right so
the they make that argument and so uh it
it certainly is not exonerating here but
the other thing that is true is look
even if we Steel Man their gender
position your gender identity died with
that past name and this new name that
you have identified with is your new
gender identity there is nothing in the
world that says that you're murderous
Persona died with your gender identity
right if you're a person prone to murder
if you're a person who hates women I
don't care that you do or you don't
identify as one my expectation is you
didn't give up your hatred of women
because you suddenly identified as well
and in fact there's a terrible I think
it is at this Festival that you were
describing where this guy is terrorizing
lesbians at at this music festival but
at some point
he is he is assaulting some woman and he
says something like you know real men a
real women have [ __ ] or something it's
right here a flyer one particularly
revolting flyer left for lesbians
featured a man with a synthetic sex
identity on the cover who's a wrecked
penis dominated the page underneath the
words real women have [ __ ] yeah so
anyway the point is I don't I don't
really care even if the guy who
genuinely did identify as female the
point is he's got a murderous rage at
women and the the whole idea of you know
dead identity doesn't make
um any sense but the point I had
forgotten earlier
was it in this piece it is also clear
that many people who are ideologically
committed to this fantasy world in which
your gender identity is something you
are just
um free to embrace at any moment and
walk away from your past life there's a
point at which this man's crimes have
been revealed and there are gender
activists who are
making excuses for him and in fact
there's a question somebody says
somebody is quoted as saying well
um I don't want to judge him for what
he's done until we know what these
people did to him that's right right and
it's the most bone-chilling
rationalization you've ever heard right
the guy has flown into a murderous rage
and killed three people a lesbian couple
in their their son this is this is a
former teacher right he's also a former
teacher so
this is not somebody who's so mentally
disabled that he doesn't know what he's
doing this is somebody who
Delights in this stuff and writes about
it and in any case the idea that will we
shouldn't want to pass judgment on this
person who is you know uh
I I hesitate to recount how horrifying
what he did to these people is but the
idea that we shouldn't pass judgment
until we figure out whether they did
something that might have in some sense
Justified
I'm sorry no just because this all flies
in the face of the stupid story you told
us about how safe it would be for
everybody to self-identify their gender
you know on a whim right this is the
story that says that's not true and now
you're not going to report it in the New
York Times in the Washington Post and
all of the other places that it should
be discussed really you're not going to
report it and when it is discussed in
other circles you're going to make
excuses for this person like
how wrong you know no you were wrong you
were wrong in the first place and we are
entitled now that these people had to
die in order to prove that we were right
that this was a danger no no they
shouldn't have had to
they were they were innocent
yeah and they were living
they were living lives that benefited
from the some of the great successes of
liberal advances of the 20th century
right this was a
black and a white woman living together
in love having adopted a black son whom
they raised to be an excellent young man
and they're all dead
and
the race of the dude who killed them
shouldn't matter at all but all of these
people who would have us believe in the
Progressive stack and that the more
points you have against you because of
historical Injustice the more right you
have to speak
the white dude who slaughtered these
three people brutally
is being protected by the media
because he pulled the trump card that is
I call myself a woman
not even a woman we don't care about
women anymore a trans woman I call
myself a woman
I'm a dude I call myself a woman that
trumps everything else
and it's the one of them that you can
100 opt into
on a whim
that's all it takes I now call myself
I'm I'm gonna call myself a man call
yourself a woman anytime you want
California's facilitating it
other states presumably will follow
surely there are people who are part of
this
who can see this
and who have some power to help reverse
it
to the extent that there are monsters
it's the category they will end up in
because it is entirely discretionary by
these new insane rules and you know this
is obviously you know I I was
um
I I think it's hard to be a decent human
and be prepared for what's described
here and you know Mandy in her
description she wasn't prepared to write
it yeah um
it's it's that horrifying but I think
you know sometimes I also say
um that to make compassionate policy
requires dispassionate analysis this is
something there's another formulation of
it that I think was written before I
ever said that which I didn't know about
but anyway I don't want to pretend that
I made that up
I think if it was new with you but it
was new to me somebody else had said
something so similar that it Bears
mention and I wish I remembered who
exactly it was but
that aside
the point is this requires a
dispassionate analysis A dispassionate
analysis says you know what
the hypothesis was if you changed the
rules in this way people would take
advantage of it people who were
specifically
um not interested were specifically
interested in utilizing the change in
the rules because of their rage at women
because of a desire to take advantage of
this category and this
is the proof that that's true you don't
get to hide it right
an honest analysis would say this is the
exception and not the rule which may be
true this exception proves why we cannot
have a rule that allows such exceptions
but you don't get to pretend it didn't
happen right by not writing the story or
by making excuses for this person
especially and but apparently you do
yeah well apparently you do apparently
you do get to pretend it didn't happen
but that that is part of why uh in this
this season when it would be great not
to be talking or thinking about any of
this we have we have spent our time here
today talking about some some true
Horrors
um that are one of the downstream
effects of the place that we started you
know with you know Stanford's list of
bad words seems trivial in comparison
but
this leads that leads to this
it does yeah
it does if if you've really become
confused about whether or not you're
assigned sex at Birth
uh or
I mean in the using the word summitle is
offensive like
yeah
the people making these lists and
policing them and making their living
doing this kind of thing
really need to build something with
their hands
or
plan a long
hike like a week
better a month three months go somewhere
outside of the country that you were
born in some were very different
language that you don't speak and
culture and food that you don't know and
make a go of it like experience things
that you can't
socially manipulate yourself into
convincing yourself that you got this
because if if these are the kinds of
lists and policies you're making you
don't got this you're really confused
yeah I would add one thing to it there
is a general change in the way we
make policy now
and the general change is an argument
carries the day
we ignore why it carries today why did
this argument about gender identity
carry the day
because of power it was not a good
argument ever but it carried the day
because of power but here's the thing
that really troubles me
how much evidence would you need before
you realized that there was something
wrong with the argument to begin with
right a rational entity
pulls out of a nosedive right at some
point it becomes clear that the
instrument that said you were flying
horizontally is wrong and you ignore it
and you pull out of the Dive Right we
are now in a situation where the wrong
argument gets to win no matter how much
evidence accumulates that it wasn't a
good argument in the first place and
this is now true effectively across the
board right okay
you inoculated how many people with this
thing which didn't do what you said it
did and did a lot of things that you
told us it didn't do right at what point
do we we're not talking about literal
inoculation we're talking about literal
inoculations at what point do we get to
say you know what the amount of evidence
that what you told us about these things
was wrong in every regard is now so
great we're not listening to what you
say about whether or not it's still
something we should be giving to people
because you turned out to be wrong right
and
this is now happening on every topic
right the people who had the power to
get their argument to carry the day in
spite of the fact that they didn't know
what they were talking about
get to be right in the end even if all
of the evidence says they weren't right
somehow they are entitled to be right
rather than advancing these things as a
proposal the point is oh they've already
concluded that they were right and the
evidence will have to be refigured in
order that they get to retain that
status of being right they were right to
begin with they remain right and it's
it's nonsense logic has never worked
this way this this has to be the flavor
of this new dark age because that's the
only case in which you would not allow
the actual evidence to change your
position right the position is what it
is for reasons that have nothing to do
with what's true
[Music]
thank you